hallo mein liebster matthias und
herzlichen glückwunsch zu deinem
dreißigsten geburtstag
wir möchten wir heute zum geburtstag
gratulieren aber nicht nur ich kari und
janus hallo matthias sondern auch all
unsere zuschauer und deswegen werden wir
heute mal all unsere zuschauer aufrufen
ihr zum geburtstag zu gratulieren
wie geht das du siehst dieses video
jetzt auf seiner geburtstagsfeier aber
das video ist gleichzeitig nachher auf
unserem youtube kanal und auf diesen
youtube-kanal wie ihr wisst ist matthias
dort regelmäßig aktiv er ist einer von
unserer gastmoderatoren und bald werden
sie sogar noch mehr von matthias sehen
denn wir machen mit ihm eine
österreich-tour viele von euch haben
sich schon das gewünscht dass wir mehr
städte in österreich vorstellen
und jetzt können wir aber zu matthias
geburtstag matthias wird an diesem
wochenende 30 und mathias wünscht sich
natürlich glückwünsche das hoffen wir
zumindest wir wissen nämlich schon mal
dass matthias sich sehr erfreut über
eure kommentare und matthias hat
tatsächlich einen google drive ordner wo
er screenshots hat von allen tollen
kommentaren die ihr ihm je geschickt hat
und seine mitarbeiterin alle hat mir ein
link zu dieser dropbox geschickt und zu
diesem google drive account und ich habe
mich total gefreut und auch ein bisschen
heute lacht dass matthias all diese
kommentare so lieb sammelt da ist zum
beispiel drin
mit danny schreibt matthias ist ein
handy oder internet matthias du bist so
schön
oder wenn haben wir dann noch diesen
schreibt hieß es
und wenn wir nach süd am montag mit es
ist sehr hübsch und sensorische
vorschreibt der matthias ist so ein
süßer und wenn wir dann noch ein update
matthias schreibt ist und kemal schreit
matthias secude
ist es matthias do really think of when
he's created in junebug in mail office
on rock at s ja ich weiß darüber hat er
sich besonders gefreut matthias ist
mathias frank albe stellt euch mal vor
matthias nach hause und liest all diese
kommentare und freut sich darüber
deshalb möchten wir heute an seinem
geburtstag die meisten kommentare
überhaupt für matthias generieren was
macht ihr schreibt ihn einfach euren
geburtstagsgruß hier unten in die
kommentare
und er wird an jeden einzelnen davon
lesen und beantworten und einen
screenshot davon machen und ihn in
seinen google drive ordner stellen
herzlichen glückwunsch matthias schade
dass wir heute nicht beide sein können
du weißt wir wären sehr sehr gerne da
aber erst wenn ihr ganz ganz liebe grüße
aus münster und wir freuen uns sehr dass
wir uns ganz bald treffen nämlich schon
in zwei wochen ganz viele küsse aus
münster zusammen mit dem fliegen hier
wahnsinnig bis bald